well a CNN crew reporting on the
protests in Minneapolis was arrested by
police live on camera look at this do
you I am under arrest sir why why am i
under arrest
that is reporter Omar Jimenez who was
showing demonstrators being arrested
live on TV he along with the production
team were then escorted away by officers
after having offered to set up in a
different location he had since been
released and spoke to the network about
his experience it did cross my mind
that what is really happening here and
the one thing that gave me a little bit
of comfort was that it happened on live
TV there's been this when you talk
within the community about let's just
say what's happened with George Floyd
there's always a discussion that what's
happening isn't new it's being filmed
and that speaks to the power of having
something happen on camera because you
can have people speak up for you without
you saying anything and that gave me a
little bit of comfort knowing that you
guys saw what was happening I was living
what was happening and the country was
seeing what was happening unfold in real
time right before their eyes you don't
have to doubt my story it's not filtered
in any sort of way you saw it for your
own eyes Boni Raddatz who's a the
advocacy director for the Committee to
Protect Journalists and joins us live
from Washington DC via Skype Courtney in
the context of the climate engendered by
the nation's leader by Donald Trump who
continually lambaste the fake news media
what do you make of the arrests of this
news team in these circumstances in
Minneapolis we're deeply shocked that
CNN reporter and his crew were arrested
live on air despite clearly identifying
themselves as members of the press
offering to comply with any police
requests to move location and this is
not acceptable in a democracy it's not
acceptable behavior by law enforcement
and of course we're concerned as we
recently reported in our latest report
on the Trump administration the media of
how this constant vilification and
harassment of the press by President
Trump and other political leaders
vilifies them and creates a permissive
environment where violence could become
more likely and frankly sends a signal
to law enforcement that hey you know CNN
is as Trump has called them the enemy of
the people
so you can't see any circumstances in
which these arrests could have been
justified based on what I saw in the
video and and you know what what we saw
the calm demeanor of these reporters the
very clear compliance with any you know
requests
no and the fact that they were not able
to verify that they were media just
seems ludicrous in light of the fact
that they were live-streaming
it wouldn't take an hour to you know
they didn't need to handcuff them it
wouldn't take an hour to verify they
could have gone on CNN and looked at the
livestream and see themselves on
television so that just does not ring
true and I think that the fact that you
heard the governor apologized clearly
indicates that no this was not
acceptable behavior and this should send
a signal more broadly to law enforcement
that they must protect the rights of
journalists to report freely and without
fear of reprisal or harassment or arrest
right it's also kind of curious or I
should say blatant really that you see a
black reporter they're being led away in
handcuffs arrested for doing his job
when a white member of the team was not
arrested
look we don't think any journalist
should be arrested for doing their jobs
but we also know that in this
environment that journalists of color
women journalists journalists who
somehow occupy a main minoritized
identity face additional harassment and
threats in doing their jobs according to
the u.s. press freedom tracker which we
helped found there have been at least
two arrests of journalists this year
nine arrests last year we saw for
example Standing Rock that Native
American journalists were arrested so
you know unfortunately I can't say you
know personally that this is super
surprising what was surprising is that
any journalists were being arrested in
America for doing their job calmly
complying with law enforcement there was
literally no excuse for that behavior on
the part of the Minneapolis Police
Department it's almost unbelievable look
at these
isn't it given the importance of this
story how concerned are you at the
ability for journalists to report what's
going on with these protests and then
knocking it forwards to November as we
enter the run in to the election we are
deeply concerned about the safety of
reporters reporting on the election on
protest on civil unrest and then you
wrap into that the challenges of
reporting during the corona virus
pandemic so in fact our cpj emergencies
which provides life-saving guidance and
support to journalists on the ground has
put out several safety advisories about
how to cover civil unrest safely how to
cover coronavirus we're working on a
whole election safety guide so this is
taking a lot of efforts a lot of
resources by us by other organizations
that are committed to ensuring that the
American public is able to be informed
during this important political period
which depends on journalists being able
to do their jobs safely and securely
record needed stay great to get your
perspective on this important story I
Cordelia right it's a committee to
protect journalists thanks very much
indeed thank you my pleasure Thanks